well we begin in Sudan where another
ceasefire has come into effect after 10
days of heavy fighting this three-day
truce was brokered by the United States
several ceasefires between Sudan's Army
and the rapid support forces have failed
to hold an at least 427 people have been
killed on the conflict the U.N says the
situation has pushed the country to the
edge of the Abyss our correspondent
hibber Morgan reports from the ground
there in khatu
more deaths in Sudan's capital hartum
several people were killed in an
airstrike in the southern city of
kalakla on Monday adding to the growing
number of Civilian deaths
the paramilitary rapid support forces or
rsf is accusing the army of directly
targeting civilians but the Army says
the rsf troops are hiding in civilian
areas and using people as human Shields
and after nearly two weeks of fighting
the rsf field commanders say their
troops control areas in the southeast of
the capital
the battle has intensified around
Khartoum airport and the fight for
information has become just as crucial
here the rsf says it maintains its
presence
to all those listening to any false
rumors that rsf are in control of the
general command or the airport we are
now inside both facilities
but Sudan's Army denies giving up power
as you can see from the green square up
to this point there is nothing but the
Army Personnel they're now combing the
area for rsf Fighters
[Music]
the video of what it says are rapid
support forces Fighters surrendering in
and fascia Azura in the Southeast
and the general meeting troops in the
main command of the Army in Hartung the
conflict has led to a major humanitarian
crisis millions of people in the capital
are trapped in their homes with power
outages no running water and lack of
food the chaos has spread to state
prisons where hundreds of inmates from
kober National prison have escaped
others from Silver prison were captured
by rsf groups
while the fighting reaches on those who
can are trying to flee several countries
including Italy France Germany and
Jordan are the latest to pull out their
diplomatic staff and foreign Nationals
with no one to rescue them Sudanese
civilians are taking matters into their
own hands to find safety some traveling
by bus to cross into Egypt getting out
of cartomo is definitely the most
difficult part of this entire Journey
um having to go through these
checkpoints where you don't know whether
you're going to be robbed or killed or
I'm just uh holding my mother's hands
looking into my grandma's eyes just all
holding each other's hands and praying
that it all goes smoothly but many still
remain behind
some say they can't afford to leave now
because of fuel and transport costs
online banking operations have stopped
and banks have been closed since the
start of the fighting and with a
breakdown in telecommunications many say
they no longer know which routes out of
hartum are safe
there have been more International and
Regional calls for mediation Ethiopia's
prime minister is appealing for both
sides to talk
I asked my brother al-burhan and my
brother hamidi to stop the fighting
immediately and adopt dialogue
Hebrew Morgan Al Jazeera hartum
well our correspondence is in Washington
DC with more on that U.S brokered
ceasefire
I think it's very interesting just how
much the US is trying to stress it was
involved in in brokering the ceasefire
following an intense negotiation over
the past 48 Hours the U.S urges the saf
and rsf to immediately and fully uphold
the ceasefire but there is another
element to that is the U.S says it's
setting up some sort of unit involving
Regional and international Partners
quote to assist in the creation of a
committee to oversee the negotiation
conclusion and implementation of a
permanent cessation of hostilities and
humanitarian Arrangements in in Sudan so
the U.S tried to show now that it is
actively involved in trying to broker
stability incident it's a fascinating
position that the U.S finds itself in
and apparently Court completely
flat-footed on that evacuation then yes
successful evacuation over the weekend
but the questions have been asked well
look after the evacuation of carbo we
were told that lessons have been learned
and the one of the key lessons was it
has to be an early evacuation before
Carol sets in that's when you do your
evacuation that hasn't happened here I
mean clearly these are different
situations and then there's the matter
of the 16 000 or so American citizens
still in still in Sudan and last week
the message was very uncompromising
saying that we've told them for years
and that you're not to be there it's
very dangerous we have no obligation
that position has come under criticism
and now we had a much more consideratory
position saying look we will try and
help some acknowledgment that the U.S
will try and help those Americans
trapped in Sudan and perhaps even try
and well they say try and have some sort
of constant presence in in Port Sudan
but they've certainly been a softening
there because there was a suggestion
that the U.S just seemed you know to
wash the hands of the whole issue
well Egypt's foreign Ministry says an
employee at its Embassy in Khartoum has
been killed in the fighting Muhammad
al-gurawi was reportedly killed while
driving to the Embassy to follow up on
evacuations for Egyptians stranded in
the country
what foreign governments meanwhile are
still scrambling to evacuate their
citizens and diplomats from Sudan a boat
carrying nearly 200 people from 14
countries has now reached the Saudi city
of Jeddah Kenyan has also just brought
over its first batch of evacuees to
Nairobi diplomats Aid workers and
students have found themselves stuck in
this conflict
speaking out a security council meeting
U.N Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
urged members to help pull the country
back from catastrophe
since the start of fighting on 15 April
hundreds of people have been killed and
thousands injured
the violence must stop
it risks a catastrophic conflagration
within Sudan
that could engulf the old region and
Beyond
I strongly condemned indiscriminate
bombardment of Civilian areas including
Healthcare facilities
and I call on the parties to stop combat
operations in densely populated areas
and to allow and hindered humanitarian
Aid operations
well Dr NADA fuddle is a Sudanese
American professor of medicine at the
University of Nebraska Medical Center
she says the Health Care system was
already dire before this conflict began
you have to remember that this came on
top of a broken and completely defunded
healthcare system without any public
health infrastructure that was damaged
through the past 30 years of
dictatorship so for a war like this to
hit a country like Sudan it's going to
cause massive consequences to the Health
Care System what I'm hearing from my
colleagues is that they cannot even find
sutures to suture wounds they cannot
find blood donation bags for those who
are willing to donate you know we have a
team in Al Jazeera state that went
trying to donate blood to the blood bank
and they were sent back because they
didn't have actually blood backs to
accept the donation the situation is
horrible in side cartoon but it's also
horrible in Nyala in al-fasher in the
internal displaced camps in what madani
and other states where people are
fleeing there's a lot of injuries and
there's also the chronic diseases which
are not being able to be managed right
now the ones who are suffer the more
civilian the peaceful civilians who are
trying to Aspire for their dream of
peace freedom and uh safety and justice
for the past several years and these are
the entities that are suffering the most
whether it's from the lack of security
whether it's from lack of daily
necessity such as food and water and
electricity internet communication is
spotty and cutting down we're not able
to launch our training program that we
collaborate with project echo in the
past to train these Healthcare
personnels on how to provide first aid
to Injured people because of the spot of
communication but there's so many people
suffering right now in Sudan just to be
able to obtain food and water those main
basic necessities and then the fear of
safety the fear that you could be at
your home and could be attacked at a
moment and displace from your home and
you could be bombed at any moment I mean
the terror the emotional toll on these
people is absolutely astronomical at
this point so there's an urgent call to
the International Community to try to
create safe routes for people to exit
cartoon or for medical personnel to be
able to provide safety and Aid to those
in need
well many people are fleeing Sudan's
capital in fear of worsening conditions
there residents of Khartoum are filling
all the available buses heading out of
the city between 10 to 20 000 have
already fled to Chad which is already
home to some 400 000 Sudanese refugees
who've LED previous conflicts many are
seeking Refuge to the north too in Egypt
where they face overcrowding and in
uncertain ways
we would like to thank the Egyptian
people and Egypt for the warm welcome
hosting and treatment but there are some
missing points I would like to point to
there's overcrowding and we need quicker
Services people are coming with very
high tension and panic from a state of
War so please we need to deal with the
situation quicker in dealing with the
entry of people I know the stress for
the Egyptian authorities is very high
sometimes I would be going to the
supermarket to buy stuff for the
children then the sound of gunfire would
force you to go back and lock yourself
up
the children would be under the bed we
put the bed mattress on the ground and
when the children hear gunfire they go
under the bed the fear that we observed
in our children even us as adults we
comforted our children while we were
scared I hope the war ends and security
and stability returns to Sudan and its
people